the former co-owner of a Massachusetts
compounding pharmacy has been sentenced
to nine years in federal prison for his
role in a deadly meningitis outbreak
Barry Cadden was head pharmacist of the
New England compounding center at the
time of the 2012 outbreak 64 people died
nationwide and hundreds of others became
sick Jim Axelrod has been following this
story from the very beginning Jim good
morning
oh good morning in March cotton was
convicted on conspiracy and fraud
charges but not on acts of second degree
murder related to racketeering however
the way the judge handled the verdict
may have allowed Cadden to escape a much
harsher sentence something that has
angered the families who lost loved ones
in this case Sharron windgates husband
died after receiving a contaminated
steroid shot Darryl Nealon lost his
father me my brother my sister he was
our foundation
Robyn Hannah bath survived but says she
still suffers from the effects of the
tainted shots I can't go Barry Cadden
left court after the sentencing without
saying a word you think it was a fair
sentence Barry but inside he had made a
tearful apology to those affected saying
I am so sorry for your extraordinary
losses a dozen victims gave emotional
impact statements I think nobody could
hear those statements without being
moved to tears many of us were the US
Attorney's Office was also hoping for a
longer punishment urging the judge to
sentence Cadden to 35 years this was an
unusual verdict slip the final verdict
form revealed the jury was split on
multiple charges including the more
serious acts of second-degree murder
related to racketeering typically that
would prompt the judge to send them back
for more deliberations the judge did not
question the numbers on the form the
jury affirmed the verdict and the case
was closed I believe that justice has
failed
don't I really do the victims families
tell us they feel like the judge robbed
them of not only a longer sentence for
Cadden potentially life in prison but
they also feel robbed of the justice and
hearing the word guilty in relation to
the deaths of their loved ones well it's
tough for those families you can clearly
see and hear their pain doing that story
thank you Jim